all right our next guest is known for
asking rhetorical questions after big
victories and driving a minivan
he earned academic all-american honors
at Michigan State for being a
kinesiology major which means he's
basically a gym teacher even though it's
Thursday Dan Patrick show fans know how
much he loves Friday Friday please
welcome the Vikings quarterback Kirk D
Cousins
[Applause]
[Music]
looky here looking good buddy thank you
for coming by guys how we doing Kirk
deke
see I I made this mistake I would I
would go Kurt cousins and then it sound
like it was saying K you Artie right
can't do that so I had to slow it down a
little bit so you're always Kirk D
cousin I love it how do I know what your
middle name is Daniel Oak okay well then
the B works weird uh Kirk it you're just
right just saying Kirk the way you do
Kirk D cousins what did you make of our
conversation of adding another like a
17th game for the regular season where
do you stand well I don't think that
players bodies need a 17th game but
there are other things to gain you know
if Jerry Jones is valuing at a billion
dollars of extra revenue players are
gonna get a portion of that and when you
have such a small window to play
professional sports it would seem a
portion of a billion dollars is gonna is
gonna help players careers and post
careers you know so that's kind of the
value is you know giving one more week
for potentially an earning potential
that could really help guys what about
adding another bye week I think that
also makes the 17 games easier to take
if if you can give guys another break at
some point in the season I know that we
will really look forward to our bye week
it's a big deal and it may extend the
season but if it makes playing 17 games
more physically doable then I think it's
something to talk about I'm pretty much
open to anything as long as there's a
give-and-take how do you feel on Mondays
normally during this yeah I I wake up
pretty sore and I don't even play the
most physical position by any means in
fact quarterbacks getting safer and
safer every year but you know you feel
like you've been in a car accident I
mean all the muscles in your neck or
sore
it hurts to turn your head and that's
just playing quarterback you know
getting hit and your head hitting the
ground a few times I can't imagine if
it's play after play after play as a
center or a guard or a three technique
so it's a grind and but you make it a
priority to get healthy and by Friday or
Saturday you're feeling good again and
then you getting another car accident
but do you would you do anything to play
in a game like that they said we're
gonna shoot you up you know you got to
talk about you know what are the
long-term ramifications is this a
steroid that's gonna be degenerative is
it gonna have long-term effects but
certainly if I remember in college we
were playing for a Big Ten championship
it was near the end of the year having a
great year I was in a lot of pain I said
shoot me up I got to get through this
half we got to win a Big Ten title and
and that'll be with me the rest of my
life so you do it you get through it but
if it's every week I need to get shot up
that's something where I think you start
to hurt yourself for the long run
well you're 31 you got a couple of kids
now you know if you're 22 oh yeah I
guess you probably don't have as much
the long view in mind when you're
younger but they do a good job now
educating players I think even the media
has done a good job of educating just
the casual fan on the physical you know
challenges of playing this game and as
long as you know the risks think can
have the right information then you can
make the right decision for you and your
family what do you remember about that
49ers game
we got the break speed office can you
put us in back there in your position
now when you can sense guys are coming
at you pretty good that secondaries
really good like how how quick do you
have to process everything against the
Niners defense yeah they're the real
deal I feel like both teams deserve to
be in the Super Bowl which is great
because they're they're deserving
they've beaten good teams on the way
there and all year long when they were
healthy they looked like the you know
two of the best teams so I think that's
a good thing you know we were close to
them in the first half Erik Kendricks
gets an interception
we're down 14-7 and we have a chance to
go in at the end of the half 1414 we end
up kicking a field goal instead just
1410 so we felt like hey we're right
there we're kicking off to them so we're
gonna have to get a stop but then they
went down and scored and then we never
really were able to do anything
offensively in the second half and and
lost 27 10 so it was really the second
half of that game they just took it to
us and control the line of scrimmage and
like you said it's it's tough when
they're coming at you and they know you
have to throw it you know you kind of
play into their hands more concerned
about the defense in front or the second
I think it all starts with the front a
pass rush but when you look at it that's
the way it is on all teams you know if
you can get a great pass rush or a great
front that can stop the run everybody
you've found it benefits if if you don't
have a great pass rushing you have great
cover guys usually you can still get
after those great cover guys because you
know a pass rush isn't getting home so
it starts with with the front if Patrick
mahomes called you and said hey you help
me a little bit here well would you tell
him I'd say make sure you keep the lead
in their ears back in coming after you
he also again when you're as talented as
he is and you run around you wonder can
you start to negate the pass rush or
nullify it by playing the way he plays
and there's that style you know help
them against such a good defense because
so many of their coverage rules and
things are based on the fact that you're
gonna sit back there and they're gonna
get home I also know with Andy Reid's
play calling I would think that that's
gonna you know be an asset for them but
keep a lead see if you can run the ball
a little bit and if you can you know I
think it's anybody's game we're talking
to Kirk D Cousins joining us the annual
Kirk Cousins football camp how would you
do if I brought my guys in here like how
good a teacher are you oh I could teach
him the game how to throw yeah
absolutely
really oh yeah how do you think I got
where I am I'm definitely not mahomes
when it comes to a natural you know
being a magician built me the perfect
quarterback well I think Heights
important I say that and then you got
guys like Russell Wilson Emery who are
rock stars but I think it helps to see
over the line of scrimmage if you have
to if you can have it I take it okay
whose height I think six five so
Tannehill sure okay I think I think
height helps I think agility is a big
deal so if you can be 65 and have
Russell Wilson's agility I think that's
a hard to beat arm you want big hands
big hands you know what's interesting
about like a Russell Wilson or Drew
Brees is they maybe their height but
their hand size would be equivalent to
someone who's six five or six six and I
think that's really important to not
fumble to be able to throw a good spiral
you got to
you know big hands how bigger your hands
minor minor decent I don't know what
they usually measure here to here but I
would try to get measurements in all
different directions if I'm evaluating
and I think mine would be equate to guys
probably six four six five I got guys
who try to stretch their hands yeah I
think there are exercises to stretch
your hand yeah more to pass the test but
it's gonna be a false positive in terms
of what you're actually gonna be able to
do it's kind of like when you wear
multiple socks for your height did you
do then
I did everything I could I drank like 15
bottles of water before I weighed in
because I'm pretty skinny
so I weighed in at to 14 and a half at
the combine I haven't weighed over 205
since then I was 214 yes boy I got the
official hand measurement for Kirk
Cousins at the combine okay 9 and 7/8
inches did you want that rounded up yeah
I would have appreciated that rounded up
see I'm also 6 2 and 5/8 so I say really
I'm 6 3 if you asked at a dinner party
because you round up right that's just
that's just the correct approach do you
care who wins this game I really don't I
want to see a good game I probably have
closer relationships to people on the
49ers so I find myself pulling for Kyle
Shanahan and some of his coaching staff
but and you know also being a part of
the NFC probably the team that beats you
would be nice to see them win at all so
you can feel like you could claim a
second place i if you want to give a
plug for your football yeah we got our
football camp this summer we hold on
both in Minnesota and in my hometown in
Michigan Kirk Cousins org our website is
where you can sign up to go but we'd
love to have anybody come out for middle
school boys going into 6th 7th and 8th
grade and we put on a great camp for 2
days a lot of fun and hopefully people
can can be able to attend it's a good
problem to have to make the money you
make but it feels like your name and how
much you make it's it's it's together
like when I say Kirk Cousins it's 84
million dollars guarantee right would
you prefer that you didn't make that or
that we didn't know about that I would
just I would just prefer that there'd be
an awareness that that's the going rate
now for
I mean Jimmy Garoppolo is in the
Superbowl we essentially have the same
contract so you know it's just part of
playing quarterback in the NFL if you
play it well there's a market rate and
and that's what it is and currently I
mean that the rate has certainly gone up
you know when guys like Carson Wentz and
Jared Goff and Russell and air and
signing extensions Matt Ryan you know
the number keeps going up it's a moving
target but but nobody's nobody ever I
don't know of any other quarterback
where we mentioned helmet they how much
they make and I'm not quite sure why
that is I don't know but I don't fit was
because the contract was guaranteed but
I mean I think all quarterbacks
contracts are pretty much guaranteed
nobody's cutting you know Matt Ryan
nobody's cutting Aaron Rodgers so
whether it's guaranteed or not it might
as well be but yeah for some reason
people are fascinated with with the
contract I signed even though it seems
like it's pretty much what everybody's
done if that plays the quarterback
position to the first Garant all
guaranteed right okay that's probably
one yeah it didn't really change the
dollars yeah he's actually a win-win
because I took a little bit of a
discount a little more cap space and
then was able to get it fully guaranteed
so it's really a win-win the players
happy and the team is happy but I guess
the words fully guaranteed for some
reason jump off the page but it's really
not logical when you actually look at
the the math is it would you rather talk
about the 49ers than your contract yes
my height I know but you could have made
more money from the Jets correct yeah we
were in a position there but we felt
like it all comes down to and you guys
know this as a quarterback it's about
winning and we just said where's the
best place for us to have a chance to
win we felt like it was Minnesota along
with that came high expectation
certainly and we've lived with that but
I don't really care about expectations
or people talking about how much you
make if we got a great chance to win
that's where I want to be you know what
do people say to you when you walk down
the street you like that that's it
yeah yeah there's no doubt I think it's
kind of the phrase that people say when
they're not gonna stop me for a picture
they'll just walk past me and then go
you like that I heard Jim Mora one time
say that when he walks down the street
people will pass him and then go
playoffs it's you like that did you make
a t-shirt we I think the NFLPA did we
did a couple things right away back in
2015 and then any any revenue that came
in we gave to a charity which was great
but since then it's pretty much been
dormant and got you know we have fun
with it still just the look on your face
when you came off the field like who who
is that who is that guy I know it's it's
funny because that's really the
intensity I play with is more that guy
but I feel like when I'm away from the
field to be that guy I might get myself
in trouble so I try to you know tone it
down for the DP show but well but who's
the guy though that when you see him on
the field and then see him off the field
and he's completely different yeah I
think Luke Kuechly is one of those guys
I mean Luke plays the game with his hair
on fire and I remember when I trained
with him before the draft and he was
like the nicest guy very mild-mannered
and then when we play him on the field I
mean he wanted to kill you and there's
some stuff to you he was just he was
just passionate you could just hear with
the you know in between plays if there
was a questionable call he's with the
refs he's yelling at you and he
respected it you say this is why he's
Luke Kuechly why he's one of the best
players in the league is because of the
passion he brings to the game but then
steps away from the field and he's you
know just so mild-mannered and friendly
and you know different different guy
anybody make you nervous though like
crazy it's a good question there's
nobody really nowadays who's like
foaming at the mouth and you know I
think of like bill Romanowski and some
of those guys Hines Ward told me that
even the Steelers were afraid of James
Harrison who was on there I was kind of
coming up as he was on the way out but
he definitely had that vibe nowadays
it's just really good players I mean
whether it was JJ Watt or Chandler Jones
or whoever you just are aware of them
that they can ruin your day
yeah if you let them but they don't
nobody says anything to you they're not
saying I want to rip your head off and
eat your heart for the most part it's
hey man how are the kids how you doing
and I'll be coming next play in the pile
they're saying hey how are the kids I
mean not every play but you'll hear
stuff guys are nice but then between the
whistles yeah it's it's people are
trying to feed their families there
going 100 miles an hour for more
information on Kirk D Cousins football
camp you can go to Kirk Cousins org is
that best place I go best place to go
hey we always appreciate the time that
you have for us we wish you the best and
it's great it's been great knowing you
since you were at henching in state and
legs yes McLovin what we gonna be able
to throw because Kirk you know is how do
I say it's more of a precision pass
through the power pastor so I could I
watch catch with one hand exactly could
you hurt your finger last year throwing
throwing it hard so maybe this year we
can do a touch pass is that your finger
last year well I told him that to make
him feel better actually it's all
misinformation around here well then
during the commercial break maybe three
passes to McLovin okay
gladly if I put my head up can you hit
it from 15 yards away I think so Wow
I think so no no he's giving you grief
for your Kirk you're making fun of Kirk
I'm not he's trying to make you angry
Kirk it's hard you're doing wait I'm in
sunny Miami Florida you can't do it Oh
we'll take a break dak Prescott will
join us coming up next is 20 after the
hour this is the Dan Patrick show for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]